My husband and I are raising two kids on one income
and here's how we make it work.
The very first thing is that we don't spend a lot of money.
Almost all of our clothes for myself,
my husband and our sons are from thrift stores or second hand.
I'm not above going into goodwill and coming out with a bunch of stuff.
I also never buy anything at goodwill without the 20% off coupon.
Get those in your email,
you get one every month.
I sell all our used clothes on Poshmark.
We do not buy new cars, and for a long time we only had one car.
I buy generic groceries
and I do hardcore couponing and downloading all the apps.
So I very, very rarely will buy anything. Food,
clothes, anything that isn't deeply discounted.
We don't go on crazy vacations.
We just do a lot of fun things around the house.
We try make our backyard fun.
Like I said, I like to sell things on Poshmark.
I also like to do little content creation things.
I work for companies and I'll create content for them.
It isn't like a full time income or anything,
but it is enough to,
you know, make things easier for us.
So a lot of times while the kids are napping or after their sleep,
that's when I'll kind of do my little like, side work.
Well, where I'll sell stuff on the internet or I'll do TikTok stuff.
I'll do Instagram stuff,
I'll do just user generated content for different companies
and I really enjoy doing that.
It gives me kind of like a creative outlet. And, you know,
a little bit of money doesn't hurt.
Basically, a lot of those little money saving things,
a lot of those little money making things add up to a lot.
Especially when you offset it
with how much we would have to spend on daycare.
It's something we decided very early on,
right before my first baby was born.
Have a degree,
I had a good job,
but I wanted to be home with him.
And we looked at the numbers
and it was clear that we were going to have to live very, very,
very frugally if we were gonna do that.
But again, it was worth the trade off for us.
And it might not be for everyone,
it might not always work for everyone,
but I do think it is a lot more doable
and a lot more realistic than a lot of people think.
You just have to be very disciplined
and you have to kind of not think in the consumer
materialist way that so many people think today.